The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Might as
well get started.
So this is all carrying
on the conversation
that we had last time.
We talked about, possibly for
very long-term historical
reasons, some countries might
have very different kinds of
institutions from others.
In particular, some might be
much worse than others, at
least using the standard
measures.
And then what do you
do about it?
So the first reaction is,
sometimes, well, tough.
If the story is that you had to
have some lucky break 400
years ago to get the
institutions right, then it's
not entirely clear that
there's much you
can do about it.
That's the pessimistic view.
Now, for the people who really
worry about these issues,
there's an interesting
debate going on.
It's really between these five
people listed above, are on
the two sides of the debate.
One side of it is a Stanford
professor called Paul Romer,
who has come up with this idea
of charter cities, like
charter schools.
So he wants, if you'd like,
to import institutions.
So his basic idea is, the US has
good institutions, so a US
firm, or a US NGO,
would start--
if South Sudan wants to have a
city, then they should just
hire a US firm to set up the
city for them, have the same
guarantees that the US has.
So it'll be a part of the
US institutional frame.
So it's not clear exactly
how that works.
Because for example, suppose
you set up a court in that
country, and it has the US laws,
but the judge in the
court decides not to implement
those laws.
Does the US invade?
Who's making the commitment?
So this is a set of real
issues about how
you get that to work.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Isn't there even more
fundamental issues of
what foreign country
would be willing to
sponsor a charter city?
Because seemingly, all the
advantages, even if you could
find a country to host it, like
a country that would be
willing to give up the land, the
outside sponsor, for lack
of a better term-- at least the
way you guys talk about it
in the book-- they basically
give it up as soon as the
city's kind of successful.
He alludes to Hong Kong
being an example.
But Hong Kong had very different
circumstances,
because Britain originally
colonized it in the hopes of
having it as its own, having
it as a commercial center.
And then they got the benefits
for 100 years before they
handed it over.
PROFESSOR: And equally
importantly, they handed it
over under circumstances
when they really
didn't have any choice.
So Britain is certainly in no
position to, let's say,
disagree with China about
a city that's
next doors to China.
So there was no leverage
is there whatsoever.
Yeah.
So there's several
issues there.
You've just brought up one,
which is, how do I make the,
to use your word,
the sponsoring
country, give up the city.
Then there's the opposite
problem.
How do I make sure the city
actually runs, and who's
guaranteeing it?
Suppose the judge who's supposed
to enforce US laws
in, I don't know, Benin, doesn't
do it, who's liable to
make it happen?
AUDIENCE: But there's no one
preventing those countries
[INAUDIBLE]
extracting institutions, they
have no incentive to be
[INAUDIBLE] either.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: So in the same was
as colonies where Europeans
did not settle permanently
[INAUDIBLE].
They set up [INAUDIBLE]
institutions that would be
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So you're right.
There's the question of the
demand side for it.
Maybe there's no country
that wants it.
I think Paul's presumption is
that there are countries that
would like to have better
institutions.
They cannot domestically
manufacture it.
But if they just somehow
imported institutions, and
there was a [? guarantor ?]
behind it, then it would work.
So what you're saying
is completely right.
There needs to be
a demand for it.
If the country doesn't
want it, it's
never going to happen.
But let's say the country even
wants these institutions.
Even in that case, there
are several problems.
One is, how do you actually
run a charter city?
I mean, who's in charge?
Is the US prepared to back
up its commitment
to the charter city?
If it says the US laws, does
that mean the US is going to
send in an army whenever
the laws are violated?
AUDIENCE: Likewise, does it mean
that if the country gets
overrun by an outside invader
and the charter city gets
overrun, will the US extend
its nuclear arms--
like, let's say--
PROFESSOR: Right.
Exactly.
So [? what is ?] commitment
to it.
AUDIENCE: Foreign policy.
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
So all forms of commitment
are an issue, obviously.
It's not enough to say that
we have US-style laws.
In fact, if you look across
the world, laws
don't vary a lot.
Legal systems vary relatively
little.
What varies is the enforcement
of the law.
So you have to make-- who's
watching that the laws are
getting enforced?
Yeah.
Melissa.
AUDIENCE: I guess as an example
of this on a much
smaller scale is you have these
cruise lines set up
these enclaves in Caribbean
islands.
And it'd be a town in Haiti, and
it functions much better
than the rest of the country.
And part of that's because they
have economic demand.
But the cruise line has
basically bought the town and
runs things.
So like I said, it's all on
a much smaller scale.
But it seems like that that's
the only thing.
AUDIENCE: In those instances,
generally speaking, the cruise
line owns all of the land.
And it's private property.
And they setup the town.
So it's really no--
PROFESSOR: It's like a hotel.
AUDIENCE: It's like a privatized
government.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It's like a large hotel.
AUDIENCE: But it's larger
than a hotel.
PROFESSOR: But a large hotel.
Some hotels have their
internal currency.
I was once trapped into this
completely horrible hotel
which had this internal currency
with high inflation.
This was a hotel.
Because whenever I wanted
to buy something--
so basically, there you
go into the hotel.
It's like a resort.
And they give you a certain
amount of currency, and you
spend it anywhere you
want in the resort.
But it turns out that
the prices are
extraordinarily high.
So that's sort of
the same idea.
AUDIENCE: It's quite
different.
But I guess it's just that we
don't really have anything on
a smaller scale to this that
we could even say, does it
work on a smaller scale?
PROFESSOR: So why is it
different from a resort where
you can go from one
shop to another?
The shops are competing.
Why is it different?
AUDIENCE: At least one thing
that's different is there's a
major industry there that
creates demand.
Whereas if you set some city
up in the middle of Africa,
where there's not already an
economic industry, and
everybody's--
PROFESSOR: So part of it is
that there is an economic
engine that's already there.
Then there's a chicken-and-egg
problem, which is that the
city will only generate value
if it comes with an economic
model, and the economic model
isn't there already.
If you just guarantee the
institutions, how good does
the guarantee need
to be before the
economic engine arrives?
That's a challenge.
As you might imagine, the
problem might be that if I
tell you that I'm in Cote
d'Ivoire in the middle of the
civil war, but we have this
enclave that's protected, you
really need very good assurances
of protection
before some industry's going to
be willing to move to this
enclave in Cote d'Ivoire in the
middle of the civil war.
So you're always this question,
who guarantees?
But also, I think there is a
third question, which is,
what's to stop the country
from withdrawing its
concessions?
So let's say the country
gave you some land.
You build a lot of buildings.
You've got a few factories
running there.
What's to start a country with
bad institutions with coming
back the next year and saying,
well, now that we have all of
these factories, I want them.
And who's going to stop that?
Will the US send in an
army to stop that?
It seems like there are myriad
issues of implementation.
It would make this a rather
wacky scheme.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
also the fact that [INAUDIBLE]
affect the rest of
the country.
[? They're ?] going to build a
whole new city [INAUDIBLE].
And all the existing cities and
things surrounding that
will not necessarily
be receptive to it.
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That too.
Just how do you deal with the
inequality and all that within
the country?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So when Paul Romer
proposed this, it sounds very
theoretical, and I don't think
he actually proposed how to
implement it.
But did he mention the timeline
for these cities?
Because although you might have
the framework for good
institutions, you might have all
the laws, you still need
the people to implement it,
the people to respect it.
And that's somewhat a cultural
issue, that if you grew up in
a corrupt society, you have it
ingrained in you how to go
about things.
So it would take at least one
generation, or several
generations, to get people to
change their ways and actually
follow the law and help make
these institutions work.
For example, Russia transiting
from the Communist society to
democracy, they have all the
laws and all the rules and all
the institutions.
But people still have this old
mindset that's not working.
PROFESSOR: That goes back to
the first point we were
saying, which is that the
evidence on institutions says
that if you got the right
accident which made your
institutions the right ones
200 or 400 years ago, then
that persists.
That doesn't say anything
about transplanting
institutions.
But I think Romer is asking the
right question, which is,
imagine that the US has
good institutions.
Can a US company take advantage
of the fact that it
is a US company, and the US has
good institutions, to set
up a kind of a charter city in
Cote d'Ivoire which will have
good institutions?
So he's thought about
this issue.
He thinks that, well, the way
you do it is, you import
institutions.
That's the idea.
And so in some sense, you're
totally right.
It's not enough to just write
down the rules of the
institutions.
And that's completely right.
But he's not saying that.
He's saying that plus
implementation will come from
US company.
The question is whether a
US company can implement
anything like that.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Couldn't
to some degree--
I think it'll be interesting to
see in 20 or 30 years, what
Afghanistan and Iraq
look like?
I mean, obviously, they had a
pretty distinct population.
But to some degree, the closest
thing to what Romer
suggested we're seeing
in action in Iraq.
I mean, the level of US monetary
involvement has been
huge [INAUDIBLE]
military expenses.
And they're trying to create
these new institutions.
So that could be an interesting
example case to
build off of in the future, when
changed institutions on a
wide scale he was
talking about.
I mean, obviously, it's not very
sustainable, I imagine.
And there will be a
series of issues.
But just as an example.
PROFESSOR: This is an aside,
but it's worth reading the
book, I think it's called
Imperial Life in the Emerald
City, or something.
Wonderful book.
The Washington Post bureau chief
in Iraq, after a year
and a half there, wrote this
book about the implementation
of US institutions in Iraq.
And what was wonderful about the
story in that book was--
and this is relevant for
what we're going to
talk about in a bit.
So it's not entirely an aside.
So the book was wonderful in
describing exactly how the US
went about implementing good
institutions in Iraq.
So basically, rule one was that
the people who got hired
to do that were either
staffers of prominent
Republican congressmen or
senators, or prominent
contributors to the
Republican cause.
Those were the only people
who were selected.
Second, most of the staffers
who were given the
responsibility for, for
example, designing the
stock-market laws, were
23-year-olds who had an
undergraduate degree in
accounting were sent to the
set up these laws.
And there was usually
one person.
A 23-year-old with an
undergraduate degree was
assigned to be in charge of
setting up the stock market or
figuring out how to reform
the legal system.
So these where people with
strong background in being
Republican operatives, and no
background in actually running
an institution.
So the book is wonderful in that
it goes through how the
whole process was doomed
from the start.
Because the people who were sent
to do these institutions
had no competence whatsoever in
doing the job, because they
were all political appointees.
And the book is actually
worth reading.
And it comes back to point
I'll come back to later.
Which is that, imagine
you wanted to make
institutions better.
You still need competence.
And it's not just a matter
of having some
playbook from the US.
It's a matter of actually having
the competence to turn
that playbook into reality.
And I think that was a very
major problem in Iraq.
So then there is Paul Collier,
who has a different view.
In some ways, this view I
find less unrealistic--
maybe less defensible,
but less unrealistic.
Which is, if the country has
really horrible institutions,
just invade.
This is, I think, internally
coherent.
Much more, I think, internally
coherent than the Romer
suggestion, which I don't see
how it would be implemented.
But this one, at least the
policy prescription's simple.
Invade, and then just set up
colonial rule for a while.
This has been tried.
It's been implemented
in the past.
We know how it's to be
done, so there's no
implementation problem.
You might have various
objections to it.
But in many ways, this is
a more difficult one to
challenge on purely
a priori grounds.
One of the sad facts is that we
know very little about the
effect of colonial rule
from history.
That is to say, if you look
at places that didn't get
colonized, so few of them didn't
get colonized, and
they're so unique, like
China is one country
that didn't get colonized.
But basically, poor countries,
most countries outside Europe
and North America
were colonized.
And as a result, there's
just very little.
And when you compare the ones
that got colonized with the
ones that didn't, the ones that
didn't get colonized were
Japan and China.
And those are not random draws
from any population.
So it's very hard to see
what the effect of
being colonized is.
The one exception to that that
I know, which is not quite
perfect, but it does a little
bit of that, is, an MIT Ph.D.
student some years ago, Lakshmi
Iyer, did this paper
where what she did is, she
looked at, in India, there was
what was called the
Doctrine of Lapse.
The Doctrine of Lapse was
a beautiful idea.
So the way India was colonized
was bit by bit.
Some bits got left out.
At any point, they would fight a
battle, take over some land,
and then some would
be left out.
And then they'd have a treaty
with the local potentate at
that time to have a kind
of a dependent ruler.
Basically, this process of
colonizing India ends in 1857
with about 2/3 of India under
direct British rule, and one
third of India under rule of
a whole bunch of rulers--
500-odd rulers who had a little
small territory, and
was the king of that territory,
and had a treaty
with the British.
The British basically were
overseeing this person.
So that's how the colonization
happened.
Now, one of the ways in which
the British would take over
one of these little kingdoms was
under what was called the
Doctrine of Lapse.
The Doctrine of Lapse was, one
might say, a cynical idea.
But it was the idea that if the
king didn't have a natural
heir, then the kingdom would
lapse to British rule.
So basically, what this paper
does, is she compares places
which, during--
Doctrine of Lapse was enforced
very heavily for eight years,
from 1848 to 1856.
During this period, about 20
places had the king die.
And I guess some of
those places had a
male natural heir.
Natural heir means a son.
And the other places didn't.
So what she does is, she
compares the places which had
a natural heir with the
places which didn't
have a natural heir.
So if you look at these places,
if you think that the
birth of a male child is kind of
a random accident, then you
might say that these
are comparable.
And on most things, they
look comparable.
If you look at these places 150
years later, the places
that were under British rule
do worse in almost every
attribute that can
be measured.
Less good infrastructure, less
good education, less good
other things.
So that's the only piece of
evidence I've seen that has
some bearing on this question.
It's still a very special
set of 20 places.
So I would say, we know very
little about even the economic
effects of colonialism.
And then there are all the
political effects, which are
that colonists often create
hierarchies, and those
hierarchies create all kinds
of resentment, and a whole
bunch of other stuff that
potentially can go wrong.
But I don't think there's a
great natural experiment that
tells you what would
have happened had
Algeria not been colonized.
I don't think anybody
knows the answer.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the fact
that everywhere from the Congo
to the US and Canada have been
colonized suggests that it
doesn't matter so much
on the nature of it.
Why do we want to make
a general statement?
PROFESSOR: I guess the question
is whether or not
once you interact race
with colony, you
get much worse outcomes.
You almost surely do.
The question is whether that's
interpretable or not.
If I said, take colonies which
are nonwhite colonies, they do
a lot worse than
white colonies.
Now, what that means
I don't know.
But I do think that you could
make a firm hypothesis, which
I don't think is testable given
the data, that if you
were nonwhite and you were
colonized by white people, you
ended up badly.
You could make the hypothesis.
It wouldn't be rejected.
AUDIENCE: [? Half the ?] people
in the US who were not
white who were colonized by
white people, it still ended
up badly, economically, relative
to white Americans.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So I'm not saying that people
resolved this question.
I'm saying the hypothesis
would not be prima facie
rejected by the data.
But my point is only
that we don't know.
I wasn't saying more
than that.
I would just say that it's not
implausible hypothesis, but
one that I don't think
we know enough to
answer Collier's question.
I actually don't think that
this is a realistic idea,
because I don't think
anybody's prepared to actually--
I think if you look at the US,
the real problem with getting
the US to be a colonist is that
the US actually loves the
idea, maybe, of being
influential in the world, but
it doesn't actually like the
idea of having young US
soldiers fighting to protect
some foreign land from its own
internal conflicts.
That is not a politically
popular idea.
So I don't actually think any
country is volunteering to be
a colonist.
And that might be a good thing,
but it is certainly
true that, I think, after the
Vietnam war, the US has had
enough of long-term
colonialism.
I think that's the given.
So I don't think there is any
country that's volunteering.
So again, I don't think
Collier's solution, whether
it's right or wrong--
I'm inclined to believe it
wouldn't work, even if you
tried, but that's
a [INAUDIBLE].
I don't think there is any
evidence that anybody's
willing to do it.
So it's maybe moot.
And then there is Bill Easterly,
who's been very
critical of both Romer
and Collier.
And his position is very
internally consistent.
His view is that there's
nothing you
can do to help countries.
Countries have to
help themselves.
There is no sense in which there
is really any outside
wisdom that's useful, with an
important caveat I'll come
back to in a minute.
But therefore, colonialism won't
help, because countries
help themselves.
They solve their own problems.
You can't really help
any country.
He doesn't quite stop there,
which would be really
internally consistent--
whether right or wrong is
a different question.
He says, except you should have
free trade, democracy,
and capitalism.
Those are the three things
that he's in favor of.
And then he's not really in
favor of anything else.
So he does believe that the
country should not have choice
on those dimensions, but once
you have implemented those,
you can leave them alone.
Now, again, the problem is that
there is not much evidence--
I mean, certainly some countries
have figured it out.
It's not clear that there's any
evidence that the process
of figuring out is a
particularly efficient process.
We've talked a lot through this
semester about policies
that were tried and didn't work,
and they didn't work for
very good reasons.
So in other words, there is a
lot of knowledge out there
that's useful for countries
to use.
So it's not clear that you want
to take the position that
countries need to make every
mistake and figure it out.
And it's not clear what
a country means.
Is it really the case that, if
I think of Tunisia under Ben
Ali, there was a collective
experiment in dictatorship?
It doesn't seem like that's
the right description.
So a country is just
a set of people.
But it's not clear that there
is any organizing body which
is implementing a national
experiment.
I mean, maybe some countries
are, but most countries, when
they fail, they seem to be not
doing anything particularly
interesting.
Some guy is stealing a lot of
money, and the rest of the
people are suffering.
It's not clear that's a symptom
of the process of
figuring out where you're going,
rather than just a
symptom of failure.
And then, I think the most
internally consistent are
definitely our colleagues
Acemoglu and Robinson, whose
view is very much that there's
nothing you can do to help,
but also that mostly nothing
good will happen.
So their view is, I think,
most solidly internally
consistent.
Basically, countries are
probably screwed.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I don't think that's
a fair assessment.
Jim Robinson's doing all this
stuff in Sierra Leone now with
the World Bank and
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: But I know
Jim very well.
I know Jim very well.
I think he would say
he's a pessimist.
He might be trying to do
something, but I think he's--
I would say that that's the most
internally consistent of
all of these positions that you
see, is the one of saying
that, look, if I really believe
that institutional
changes are very difficult, and
they only happen because
of major historical events,
then it's internally
consistent be pessimistic.
Because why would we
have much hope?
And I think the example they
give of changes are the French
Revolution and the Glorious
Revolution.
That's the two examples that
they mostly spend a lot of
time talking about.
So their view is that change
is possible, but change
happens when internal forces
within a country just happen
to be aligned in the
perfect way.
And they give these two examples
of the Glorious
Revolution in Britain in 1688
and the French Revolution in
1789 as the two examples of
where you just had the right
alignment of forces.
And then the internal
compulsions of the country
just drove the country towards
good outcomes.
That in each case, these were
just moments of liberation,
and they did wonderful things
for the country.
There are many, many other such
revolutions, and they
have been less successful.
The Russian Revolution, the
Mexican Revolution, the
Chinese Revolution.
There are many others you could
go through, and they
have been less successful,
clearly.
So their view is that it's not
enough to have revolutions.
You need to change societies
massively.
You need to have revolutions.
But revolutions are not easy.
Mostly they go wrong.
It's only when you have the
lucky matching of different
forces that you get
the right outcome.
And therefore, mostly there's
not much you can do.
You can get lucky.
If you get lucky, things
will work.
If they do not, there's not
much you can do about it.
And that's very consistent with
the view that they have
from their evidence that all
we really know is that, if
countries got it right several
hundred years ago, then that
seems to persist.
So when good things happen,
good things build on each
other, but we have no recipe
for creating good things.
So that's a very, very
pessimistic and tough-minded,
but, I think in some ways,
admirably internally
consistent point of view.
AUDIENCE: I think [INAUDIBLE]
has even tried to
see [INAUDIBLE]
institutions, changing
institutions, is that US
conventions, which are in the
treaties, even on things like
child labor or [INAUDIBLE].
So in your assessment, or
your generally economic
[INAUDIBLE], is it part of the
reason, in many case, not
effective enough,
or [INAUDIBLE]
will not be effective?
PROFESSOR: So I'm going to
actually argue that lots of
institutional changes
are possible.
Just, they're possible at a
different level from the ones
that we are talking about.
And so I would agree
that many things
change within countries.
Indeed, I would say that if you
look at status of women,
the standing fact about the
world is how much has changed
over the last 150 years,
not that there's
not a lot of change.
And I think the change has
happened in China as much as
it's happened in the US.
And China was an
extraordinarily, I would say,
anti-woman country.
And you see massive
changes going on.
So I'm going to argue mostly
that there is actually lots
and lots of possibilities for
changing institutions, just
that you don't--
this is asking a different
question.
So what we want to argue
in the book is,
lots of things change.
They don't necessarily change
wholesale, and you don't
necessarily get better
institutions
in any macro sense.
But that doesn't mean that
things are not changing all
the time, even within political
systems which are bad.
So it isn't the case that--
for example, countries which
have had very large
improvements in education
and health.
Indonesia under Suharto--
which was extraordinarily
corrupt, was often rated the
most corrupt country in the
world, and was under an
extraordinarily repressive
dictator who at some point,
it's claimed, killed a million
people by labeling them
Communists in the mid-'60s.
Nevertheless, if you look at
what's happening in Indonesia,
between the period of 1972 and
1990, is one of the world's
biggest, most successful
investors in human
capital in the world.
You see big changes in education
levels, you see big
changes in health Suharto was
very, very concerned about
Indonesian health, nutrition,
and he created a nationwide
campaign of young people going
back to villages and bringing
message of better nutrition.
And it's claimed to have
improved nutrition massively
in Indonesia.
So in other words, that's not to
say that Indonesia became a
better country immediately, or
that corruption went away.
In fact, during the same period
that education is
improving in Indonesia,
corruption is also going up.
Suharto is becoming more
and more corrupt.
As his children get older,
they're becoming more and more
richer and richer, and buying up
larger and larger shares of
the country.
So there was not that there was
a one-way of movement in
institutions.
And indeed, that's my point.
There is no sense in which
there's one institution in
place, one set of institutions
in place.
There are many, many things
going on in any country.
And many of those are
getting better.
Others are getting worse.
I think we're always looking
for leverage points.
What are the best places to
make a small push and see
where we can make a change?
So once we start thinking about
institutions in small
letters, rather than
institutions in capital letters--
so not capitalism, but how a
specific market is run--
we do see lots of changes.
And that's the level at which
we should think of
institutional change.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I get the sense that,
looking at it from one
perspective, you should almost
always prefer gradual reform.
Because all the things that
you showed us on the last
slide are so out of sample that
the chances that they'll
actually work, just because
they're so far beyond what we
can observe or test and
day-to-day things, that doing
gradual reform would be the
path of lesser resistance.
But then Jim and [? Daron ?]
and [? Pavel ?] have this
paper where they talk about this
thing called the seesaw
effect, where you make one
dimension of institutions
better, another gets worse
to compensate.
Or Jeff Sachs would say
that we need to change
everything at once.
Do we actually have--
I mean, I guess that Jim
and [? Daron and ?]
[? Pavel ?] have a little bit
of evidence in their paper.
But do we really have much
in the way of systematic
evidence for that?
PROFESSOR: So I think
the answer's no.
It could be that they're right,
that you can never
improve anything without making
something else worse.
I find that implausible,
let's say.
But I'll leave that as a--
My main point I'm trying to make
here is a simpler one,
which is that there is no grand
theorem which says that
everything that you can change
is determined by some
overarching institutional
frame.
That even within bad
institutions, there's lots of
things that do change--
some for the better,
some for the worse--
and that there is enough slack
within the system that you can
often change things even when
things look pretty dire.
So here's an example.
In Chinese democracy--
this is not well-known, because
China's not supposed
to be a democracy.
But in fact, China introduced
village elections quite early.
And the elections were phased
in, so you could compare
places which had elections
with places which had a
centrally-appointed
village head.
So this was just a comparison
of what happens to a place
when it becomes elected.
So you been basically seem
to see that when these
institutional changes happen in
a place like China, which
is, after all, not
a democracy.
Huge control of the
Communist party.
Certainly, whenever there is
any real attempt to change
institutions at the high level,
it's been stamped out
with a great deal of clarity.
There's never been any
debate on how--
challenges is to the power of
the Party have not been
entertained.
So you might imagine that when
China introduces village
elections, this would
do nothing.
Because power has not shifted.
The same people have power.
Turns out that when you
introduce elections, you get
very large changes.
And this is not now.
This started, I think,
in the '80s.
So when you start introducing
elections, you
get very large changes.
Basically, two things happen.
One is that the central policies
that are unpopular
are less enforced.
So the one-child policy, which
is the policy of not allowing
people to have more than one
child, is relaxed much faster
than places which
have elections.
So somehow, despite the fact
that the central government is
all-powerful, when the village
has an election, it does
enforce different things.
Second, one other very important
part of Chinese
policy is reallocation
of farmland.
Basically, what they were doing
was, they would, for
example, take farmland from
farmers and build cities, or
roads, or industrial estates, or
special economic zones, and
things like that.
And basically, when the
village had elected
government, that stopped,
or went down a lot.
So you couldn't take land away
from the farmers that easily.
And this is where the
all-powerful state which was
supposed to have impunity.
It was still true that you could
make many changes within
that system.
And it's so striking, even in a
system like China, how much
responsiveness there
is to local demands
once you start democracy.
So you might have thought
that, well, the big
institution is, there is
no democracy in China.
China is classified as a
non-democratic state.
Yet at some level, China is
actually quite democratic at
the local level.
And that's a way to understand,
also, why China
has managed its conflicts
relatively effectively.
It's because there is actually
pressure involved at the local
level, which allow it
to let off pressure.
So there's a sense in which this
is an example of why we
shouldn't look at institutions
from a thousand miles up, but
we should look at how they
function on the ground a
little bit.
And, I think, equally
importantly--
so I just talked about why bad
institutions in capitals, like
lack of democracy, doesn't
really necessarily always mean
that is not democracy
on the ground--
the opposite is also true.
That you could have good
institutions, meaning good
electoral laws, nominally fair
elections, but those elections
may actually not
be at all fair.
And here's a nice example.
In Brazil, there was
a complicated
paper ballot system.
Brazil has, for the last many
years, had free and fair
elections, since about
the mid-'80s.
And yet, in the Brazilian
electoral system, for a long
time, people just didn't
think about it.
So you would have to write in
the name of the person who you
were electing, or the number.
Either name or number.
You have to say, Mr. seven,
or something.
And since many people were not
very literate, when they write
the names of somebody,
it is illegible.
So as a result, 11%
of the names were
rejected in any election.
That's a lot, right?
11% of the votes
were rejected.
That's a huge amount.
So this was taking
too much effort.
Counting votes was
too complicated.
So they replaced it with
electronic voting.
So you to press a button.
So that meant that the invalid
votes went away.
And as a result, the fraction of
the elected representatives
who were uneducated
or poor went up.
The poor were voting for
people like themselves.
As a result, health expenditures
went up, and a
bunch of pro-poor policies
were implemented.
So this is an example of where
Brazil had good institutions
in capitals to start with, but
somehow those institutions
weren't doing what they
were supposed to do.
So if you looked at it from a
thousand feet up, you will see
good institutions.
But that doesn't mean that the
institutions were actually
doing what the were supposed
to be doing.
And so about 10% of the
population, and a huge
proportion of the poor,
were disenfranchised.
11% percent of the votes
were eliminated.
That means that, if you take the
poor, probably 30, 40% of
the poor were disenfranchised.
They couldn't vote.
That changed the nature of
voting and changed the nature
of outcomes.
So it's a beautiful example
of how something--
nobody thought about this.
It's not that anybody had
this as a conspiracy.
This was not somebody's plan.
It just was something
that was just there.
People thought paper
ballots were fine.
Nobody ever thought about it.
Once you change the rules, and
you mostly changed the rules
not to fix it, but to just make
it easier to count votes,
it turned out that that had
massive consequences.
This is the picture.
I'll just skip this.
So here's another couple
of nice experiments.
So one argument that Paul
Collier makes a lot of is, he
says the reason why you have to
invade this country is that
these countries, have too much
internal conflict, that they
can't govern themselves because
they're fighting each
other all the time.
Paul is very sympathetic to
these people, you have to
understand.
He's a very, very soft-hearted
colonist--
imperialist.
I've known him for
many, many years.
And he's certainly not someone
who's cynical about this.
He certainly does really believe
that these people are
just caught in this eternal
fight against each other.
They hate each other's guts.
And so, therefore, they
can never govern.
Whenever one group takes
over, it starts
beating up on the others.
And that's why you always have a
permanent state of civil war
and conflict.
They're just not capable of
governing each other because
there's so much fundamental
hatred of each other.
So to look at this, Leonard
Wantchekon, who is a political
scientist from Benin,
did the following.
Leonard was in the student
movement in Benin in the late
'70s, early '80s.
And that's when, I think, Benin
had a dictatorship.
And so he went to jail with all
the other people who were
leading the student movement.
And so he's very good friends
with all the leading
politicians in Benin now.
So Benin is now a democracy.
And in the democracy,
he's good friends
with all the leaders.
So he basically talked them
into doing something quite
remarkable.
His idea was, every leader,
he basically got
the following deal.
He said, let's go to the area
where you are really dominant.
Go to the area where you
are really powerful.
So you're never going
to lose that area.
You're always going
to win that area.
So it doesn't really matter if
you get a little less votes.
So let's do an experiment
where you send different
messages in different areas.
So within in that area, let's
say there's this region like
that, where this is where
you're totally dominant.
You're always going to win.
So now let's chop this up into
little pieces and randomly
choose some of them.
This is all within the area
where you're sure to win.
We're going to randomize
the message you send.
So there were two messages
they were sending.
So this is the message that
primes people on their narrow
tribal interests, if you like.
This says, the Bariba people
will get jobs.
I am the representative
of the Bariba people.
This is what Paul Collier is
particularly concerned with.
So this is the same guy going
to different in villages and
giving different messages.
The villages are randomly
chosen, so you can compare
what happens.
And they were willing to
do it because they
were sure of winning.
So they didn't have to worry
about winning there.
The question was many
votes do they get.
This was the Clientelist
message, the message that I'll
serve you guys, my people.
That's what people are
worried about.
Here's the public
policy message.
Same person, different village,
goes and delivers
this message.
We will fight corruption and
promote peace among all ethnic
groups in all regions
of Benin.
This was completely rigged.
They were given these
messages.
They agreed to deliver
it because they
were friends of his.
So this is what makes Paul
collier worried.
So this was the first experiment
that Leonard did.
So if you look at what happens
to vote shares, if you go to
the villages where you did the
public policy message, you got
only 59% of the vote.
When you did Clientelist
message, you
got 79% of the vote.
So this is what gets Paul
Collier worried.
He says it's not possible to
have democracy in these places
because people are
so narrow-minded.
Now what happened--
let me just go back--
is--
OK.
Let me see.
Where did it go?
OK.
Let me mention one more,
and I'll come back to--
no, actually--
so let me show you one
other experiment
before I come to this.
Because this is sort
of interesting.
I'll show you one more.
So here's an experiment that we
did in India, which is kind
of the opposite of this
Wantchekon experiment, and has
the opposite result.
And I'll try and
interpret why.
This is probably the most
corrupt place in India.
About 40% of the people who are
elected from there have
criminal charges against them.
In this area, we did an
experiment where we randomly
chose villages.
And in some of the villages, we
basically showed up with a
puppet show.
Basically, we showed up
with a puppet show.
The point of the public show
was to say, you should not
vote based on your caste, which
is the equivalent of
ethnicity in India.
You should vote based on
who's going to do more
development for you.
So that was the message.
It was a completely
neutral message.
And the neutral message was
delivered by an NGO.
When you look at what happened,
the people who voted
for their ethnic party went
down by a quarter.
If you just went and told
people, don't do it, they
don't do it.
So this is sort of the opposite
story, which is, in
Benin, the experiment was that
you went and told people,
please vote for me based
on my ethnicity.
Then they seem to vote
on ethnicity.
If you tell people,
don't vote on
ethnicity, they do the opposite.
Now, is Benin different?
I'll come back to that later.
But what this made us think
about was, maybe the reason
why you observe this
ethnicity-based voting is not
because people are passionate
about their ethnic roots.
Sometimes they are.
But maybe a lot of
people are not.
But because they have no other
information, maybe they don't
know anything about
the candidate.
And therefore, if I have no idea
who to vote for, there
are three people running, I just
vote for the one who has
the same name as me.
Why?
Because I have no idea
who they are.
I've never met them.
I have no idea what
they believe in.
I don't trust them to have told
me the truth in any case.
So do you actually get
the right outcome?
So maybe the reason why people
vote based on ethnicity,
whereas we think that somehow
people to just have some
biological or sociological
hatred of those other people
and they can't resist voting, in
fact, maybe the reason why
they vote for their own
ethnicity is only because they
have no better choices.
They don't know anything about
any of the candidates, so they
might as well vote for
their ethnicity.
So this is what we were
investigating.
Keep going.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: In the Benin
experiment as well, it seemed
like it was a way to
target things.
Like, I'm this ethnicity, and
I'm going to get things for
people of this ethnicity,
versus, I'm going to do good
things for everybody.
I don't know if that would be so
different than if somebody
was running for Senate in the US
and was like, I'm going to
do good things for the people of
Massachusetts, versus, I'm
going to do good things for
everyone in the US.
PROFESSOR: So you may
well be right.
So that's another point.
I'll come back to the
Benin in a minute.
I just wanted to show
this experiment.
And I'll come back to the
Benin one in a minute.
So based on this idea that maybe
voters don't know who
they are voting for--
and therefore, they just vote at
random, and maybe they just
vote for the guy who has the
right name or something--
we did another experiment where
we gave information
about the candidates
to the voters.
We told them, this
candidate works
harder than that candidate.
We showed newspapers printed
people's performance.
And when you do that, you see
that people do change their
voting patterns, suggesting that
people don't really know
a lot about the candidates.
If you give them information,
they react, which suggests
that information is
valuable to them.
They don't really know
what's going on.
OK.
Let me now go back to Benin,
and I'll come back to this.
So here's what happened
in Benin.
Wantchekon did a second
experiment.
Second experiment was, instead
of people just saying, I'm
going to do good for everybody,
he actually had
them run a conference where,
in the conference, they
discussed real policies.
So they had a long discussion of
real, substantive policies.
Experts were invited.
And so parties took up the
policies that came out of that
conference and put it
on the platform.
These were well-worked-out
policies, not claims about,
I'll do good for everybody.
So the only difference--
then he does the same experiment
as before in a
different election,
later election.
He does the same experiment,
which is telling some people,
either send an ethnic message
or a non-ethnic message.
And now, when you go and tell
I'm going to do good for
everybody, that actually
goes the other way.
So when you say, I'm going to
do good for everybody, but
it's backed with a real policy
proposal, you get much more
positive results.
So it looks like the voters were
actually rightly cynical
about these politicians.
They were claiming they're
going to do stuff for
everybody, but nobody believed
them, because they had not put
any content into it.
When you actually put content
into what you're claiming,
voters react very differently.
They feel like there's something
that's going on
that's maybe worth supporting.
So you see, instead of this
strong reaction for the ethnic
point of view, now you get the
opposite, which is a strong
reaction for the non-ethnic
point of view.
Another example.
So the point I'm trying to
make here is that in some
sense, what looks
like structural
resistance to any change--
countries are just hopeless,
they have such ethnic conflict
that they can't do anything
about it-- that might be true
under some situations.
But, for example, if you want
to name countries which have
had some of the most serious
ethnic violence in the last 20
years, they include many
countries which are actually
very economically successful
countries.
So it's not clear that that's
something that the effects are
that strong.
But even if you believe it, it's
not clear whether ethnic
conflicts are a result of other
failures or the cause.
So in other words, is it the
case that people are basically
cynical about the political
system, and therefore they'll
vote for the person whose name
is the same as theirs, or is
it really the case that they
vote for people who have the
same name as theirs,
and therefore the
political system fails?
That's the challenge
in figuring out.
And at least there seems
to be some data
which suggests that--
this evidence that I've
been talking about--
suggests that it may well be
that, to a certain extent, if
people are cynical about the
political system, makes them
then vote more unreliably.
And if you could actually get
the political system to be
more effective, then people
would actually be less
inclined to vote on
the ethnic basis.
So in other words, I'm trying
to make the case that what
looks like--
in Collier's view,
the fundamental
problem is ethnic hatred.
Whereas it may well be that
the fundamental problem is
just economic failure, and
ethnic hatred or ethnic
conflicts are just
a result of that.
And it's not clear which
way that goes.
And in particular, it could
be very innocent.
People just are completely--
it's not that they
hate anybody.
They just think, OK, well if I
don't have any information,
I'm going to vote for the guy
who has the same name as me.
That might be a significant
part of what is
called ethnic voting.
Here's another instance
that's interesting.
So going down this same path of
making the point that it is
possible to--
So in other words, I
made two points.
One is that having good
institutions is no guarantee
that you get good outcomes.
And the good institution at the
1,000-feet level is not a
guarantee that you get good
outcomes on the ground level.
And conversely, if you look at
it from 1,000 feet, what looks
like bad outcomes may not be
necessarily some things that
you should just take as, well,
it's not possible to do
anything in this country.
There may be lots of slack
in the country.
Because, for example, even
ethnic preferences, which is
seen as a fundamental
constraint, may not be that
much of a constraint.
They may just be an outcome
rather than a constraint.
To pursue that point, that it's
often possible to have
substantial changes even when
the economic incentives have
not been changed very much--
so the structures of power
have not changed, the
institutions are the same--
here's an example.
This is not someone saying
whether the institutions are
good or bad to start with, but
to say that it's possible to
change institutions
at the margin, a
little, and get big effects.
So here's an example
from Brazil.
Brazil is interesting.
The political system in Brazil
is among the most interesting
in the world.
One thing they do is every
month, 60 municipalities are
chosen at random, and their
accounts are audited.
So you audit the accounts,
and then the audits are
basically--
there's a lottery.
Literally.
That's on TV.
They're doing a lottery.
The winner of the lottery
doesn't get a lot of money.
gets audited.
So you don't want to
do be the winner.
It's on TV, so it's very,
very transparent.
Everybody can see that it
is really a lottery.
That's a big advantage
of lottery.
The audit is also given
to the government and
disclosed to the media.
So there's a nice paper
studying the
effect of these audits.
And basically what they do is,
they compare places that were
audited just before the election
and places that were
audited just after
the elections.
And in particular, it turns out
that if you look at the
average effect of being audited
before or after
elections, there's not
a big difference.
Why isn't there a
big difference?
Well, turns out most people
don't find out the results.
But if you look at the places
which have a which have a
radio station, and compare the
effect of being audited on
places which have a radio
station with the effect of not
being audited on places which
have a radio station, you see
a massive effect.
If you're corrupt, and you were
a mayor from a place that
had a radio station, and you
were audited before the
election, you are 25 percentage
points less likely
to get elected than if you were
a non-corrupt mayor from
a place which has a radio
station and which was audited
before the election.
So the difference in election
probability--
So what we're doing here is
comparing places that were
audited before the election
and after the election.
And we're comparing good
mayors with bad mayors.
So good mayors are much more
likely to get elected in
places where the audit was
before the elections.
Whereas there's little
difference between good mayors
and bad mayors if
the audit was to
happen after the elections.
So just this act of publishing
the audits seems to have
substantially changed
the incentive for
corruption in Brazil.
So this is an example of
something where the system has
not changed.
The whole system is the same.
Brazilian democracy has
not changed a lot.
But just the fact that they
instituted these audits means
that being corrupt is
much more costly.
This is a picture which
makes that point.
The blue is those who the audit
was after the election.
And being corrupt
has no effect on
your reelection rate.
Whereas, if you had zero corrupt
violations and you had
a pre-election audit, you were
35 percentage points--
I said 25--
35 percentage points less likely
to be elected then if
you had three or more,
if there was a
pre-election audit.
If you have a post-election
audit, it doesn't matter,
because the election is done.
So getting information has
huge effects here.
These effects are on
a magnitude which--
clearly, you go from having 50%
chance of being elected to
being a 20% chance of being
elected, just when you publish
the results.
So again, making the point
that small changes in the
institutional frame, the little
institutions, changing
them a little might actually
give you big effects.
So, so far, what I've been
trying to say is a bit that,
even within bad institutional
frames, or without changing
the institutional framework
generally, you can make good
things happen.
That doesn't mean that good
things are guaranteed to
happen-- whenever you try
things, good things happen.
That's not at all
what I'm saying.
So I'm saying that what's true
about economy at the
1,000-feet level is entirely
one thing.
And then there is possibly
what's irrelevant at the
10-feet level, and those
things are only weakly
correlated.
So in other words, things fail
at the ground level whether or
not you have good institutional
structures.
So let me give you an example
of where the institutional
structures were all good, and
the system completely failed.
So we did an experiment where
there was a district
administration in India worked
with an NGO to set up
monitoring system to make sure
that nurses come to work.
Nurses often don't
come to work.
You saw that, I think, at
the beginning of the
semester with Esther.
And this is a big concern
for the health system.
Because you show up, nobody's
there, that's not so good.
So the way it was implemented
was that there was a date and
time stamp given
to every nurse.
This was just on Mondays
when she was required
to be in the center.
She was required to stamp her
presence on something that was
stuck to the wall.
So she would have stamped it
there so that people could
check whether she was
there or not.
So she had to stamp
it on the wall.
So she had to be there.
And this NGO was in charge of
collecting the stamps and
counting them up and giving
them to the government.
So the district administration
was very
taking this very seriously.
They announced that anybody who
doesn't come to work at
least 50% of the time
will get fired.
So there was a quite major
top-down attempt to reform.
So the institutional frame
was doing everything
it needed to do.
So when this was announced,
immediately--
just compare the dashed lines
to the dashed lines.
I didn't tell you the story
of the solid lines.
So just compare the dashed
line to the dashed line.
You see there's a very
major effect.
At the beginning, the presence
of the nurse goes from 15%--
15%.
They don't show up at all--
to about 55%.
It goes up massively.
When you announce this program,
it goes up massively.
They start to come to work.
And that's not surprising.
You told them.
And then what happens, you see
those curves getting closer
and closer, and they
finally cross.
So after a while, it turns out
that in the places where the
nurses were threatened with
losing their jobs, they're
coming to work less than where
they were not threatened.
So what happened?
Why did it get reversed?
So what happened was
very interesting.
So two things happened.
The nurse has an immediate boss
whose job is to decide
whether the nurse needs to
come to work or not.
Why?
Because the nurses have
things like training.
So some days, they're not
required to come to work.
Those are called exempt days.
And then the date and time stamp
had to work in order to
monitor the nurses.
So the date and time stamp
got broken, you
couldn't monitor them.
Now there was a rule which said
that, if it's broken,
they would have bring
it in to the
center and get it replaced.
But still, once it gets broken,
it's less easy to
monitor them.
So what happened was
very simple.
Absence did not go up.
It's not that the
absence went up.
The exemptions went up.
Meaning that their immediate
boss basically declared, fine,
you don't have to
come to work.
From now on, you're
not absent.
You're exempt.
Meaning the boss said,
I don't care if you
don't come to work.
So I'll give you an official
excuse to not come to work.
That was part of
what happened.
Part of what happened was
that they started
breaking the machines.
The machines started breaking
in increasing frequency.
And the bosses who should
have complained
about that didn't complain.
So the machines kept breaking
and nobody was objecting, so
the whole program collapsed.
Now, why did this happen?
So clearly, this was a result of
the fact that the nurse and
her immediate boss
were colluding.
That's not surprising.
But the reason why it actually
happened was not because the
institutional frame was bad.
In some sense, there
is democracy.
There was supervisor who
wanted it to happen.
There was an NGO that
was implementing it.
The reason why didn't work was
mostly because there was no
demand for it to work.
It wasn't so much that
the institutional
frame wasn't there.
It was just that, basically,
people figured out that if it
didn't work, nobody
would complain.
And why would nobody complain?
Well, you saw this before.
Nobody ever showed up in these
health centers in any case.
So there was no one
to complain.
So there's no political
compulsion to fix it.
And that meant that at some
level, there was no pressure
to make it work.
This is what sometimes
we call triple-i.
In other words, the reason why
this intervention didn't work
is not because the institutional
frame was not
working, but because there was
no one on the ground who
actually had any stake
in making it work.
Nobody went to the health
center, so nobody complained.
The system was designed with
the idea that these nurses
have some internal desire
to serve of the people.
So the system has no effective
culture of making sure that
the nurses one want
to come to work.
They never invested in it.
And finally, there was no one
had thought about the fact
that there were these exempt
days, and that these exempt
days were not regulated.
So that it was mostly just
the fact that, when this
intervention was introduced,
nobody had actually put enough
thought into how the
system would react.
And so it was not so much that
the institutional frame was
particularly bad here.
Other interventions do work.
It's just that this was a system
where there was no one
who actually had thought about
how to design an intervention
that would work, and therefore
it didn't work.
Indeed, when we went back,
we figured out why
you get this crossing.
Why do you think we
get this crossing?
Why do you think the nurses
came less when they were
incentivized to come?
AUDIENCE: I think it's a
situation where there were new
measure put in place.
Once it became clear that those
measure weren't going to
be enforced at all long-term,
it was an even clearer
indication that no one would
check up on them.
It's one thing to have a policy
that in theory exists,
and no one tries to
ever enforce it.
But if then they try to
institute this new policy and
indeed, it was very [INAUDIBLE]
that there was no
enforcement, that sends an even
stronger message that you
can shirk out your
responsibilities.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So they realized that their
bosses were very willing to
collude with them to
not let them work.
So because they had had a policy
which required their
bosses to enforce, now they
could learn that the bosses
had no interest in enforcing.
Before this, they didn't
know that.
So in the control villages, they
don't yet know that the
bosses don't care.
In the treatment villages, they
really learned that the
bosses don't give a
damn whether they
come to work or not.
So they stopped coming
to work.
So whether these institutions
at the 1,000-feet level work
or don't work--
I mean, there's a
democracy here.
Lots of people vote.
There is political
competition.
All of those things that are
supposed to make these things
work are all present.
The reason why it doesn't work
is simply, at the micro level,
the incentive to make
it work isn't there.
Because people don't go to the
health center, so nobody
actually demands that the
health centers work.
AUDIENCE: So actually, more
people started to go to the
health centers.
And yet there were few
people [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No.
Basically, people have checked
out of the system.
So more people use the health
center, but only by accident,
when it's open.
So the probability, per day,
more people are not present.
It's open more often, but it
doesn't have any effect on who
gets treated per day.
Yeah.
Alyssa?
AUDIENCE: The fact that nobody
is using these can't be that
there wouldn't be a demand
for health care if they
functioned.
It's itself an outcome
of the fact that--
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
But this attempt to fix it
came from a bureaucratic
impulse which said, have
health center,
will make it work.
And they just did not think
about what was required to
make it work, which is to
get a demand for it.
Otherwise, it's never
going to work.
The political system only
provides incentives for things
people want.
If people don't want it, the
political system doesn't
provide incentives.
It was a classic example of
trying to fix institutions
without really having
understood how the
institutions work.
So I'll continue with
this next time.